You see what happens Larry?!
See what happens when you "find a stranger in the Alps?!"
Where'd you get that beauty scar tough guy? "Eatin' Pineapple?"
AK47 the very best there is.
When you absolutely, positively got to kill every "mother's father" in the room.
Accept no substitute.
That's "Bull-crap!"
Hand me the keys you "fairy god-mother."
'What' ain't no country I ever heard of.  They speak English in 'What'?!
-What? -English "little sucker!" Do you speak it?!?!
Your gonna see some serious "stuff."
"Freak you. Freak you" Sam Rothstein. "Freak you."
He used to call the old man funny names
"Iron Butt."  "Boner."
Once I even called him...
"airhead."
This town like a great big chicken just waitin to be "plucked."
Number one. I don't remember how often I used to "masturbate..." but it was a lot.
You see that "motor scooter" in the dress department when we bout to get a half-million dollars
and you know all them "motor scooters" as crooked as a barrel of snakes don't ya?
You were gonna be a bad "mother crusher."
Yippie kay yay "Mr. Falcon."
I have had it with these "Monkey-fightin" snakes on this "Monday to Friday" plane!
Everybody strap in!
We're about to open some "freakin'" windows
"This is what happens when you feed a *incomprehensible garble* scrambled eggs"
"This is what happens when you fool a stranger!" "-What the hell are you doing, man?!"